but I'm not one of those women I'm not  one of those women that think that women  don't need a man  do you know what I mean I'm old school  and I just feel like too they there's  parts that we but we provide to them and  they provide for us I agree do you know  what I mean yeah I feel like women are  just more delicate there's things that  we need to be protected more it's even  in Wildlife do you understand you  protect the women and the kids do you  get me I'm I'm more I'm more delicate  I'm more softer than you I'm not as  strong as you so if it comes down to the  Warren who's gonna have to fight if we  have to pick out a me and you you're  gonna have to be the one that's gonna  have to fight for us isn't it  you understand and then I protect the  kids the children after you then it  comes to me